welcome to the Tim Dylan show everybody
we are here in a week two of the
pandemic I got diagnosed with strep
throat the other day and I thought I had
the corona virus and I thought how funny
would it be if the first case of the
corona virus in Los Angeles was a guy
who would win on his podcast and said I
am for the corona virus
I want the corona virus and then the
next day I got diagnosed with it but it
was only strapped so I'm I'm better now
sort of my voice is coming back
I hadn't had strep throat since I was
like 10 that's something you get when
you're 10 and you don't realize like
being sick is fun when you're a kid it's
fun for at least a few days you can sit
at home you can watch movies back then
we went the blockbuster and I'd rent
movies get a bunch of movies watch them
over and over again my grandmother would
make me french toast and grilled cheese
being sick was good but when you get
older you know it's it's the hell you
know because there is no French Allison
Croce I mean there's nobody's making you
anything nobody cares
even if you're in a relationship or
something they don't care they they're
at work nobody nobody has the time to
when you're sick when you're older give
a [ __ ] about you that was the whole
thing like when you were younger people
used to go I'll shut down or your
grandparents didn't have to cuz they
were they weren't working they were like
yo just come here and you can be sick
and we'll get you better and we feel bad
for you and you want to get movies and
what do you want to eat you know but
shred man when you're a kid you don't
you love like a sore throat it sucks but
when you're older and you have that
strep throat and you just open your
throat and you're staring at the back of
your
you're like there's a virus in me
there's something in me I mean it's hard
to swallow and you go eventually this is
what esophageal cancer feels like it's
just every sickness when you're over
thirty is just a rehearsal for the big
one and you don't know which one that's
gonna be and you don't know when it's
gonna be but every mild discomfort you
have is a rehearsal you know every
headache is a rehearsal for the tumor
that's the way I think every sore throat
is a rehearsal for the cancerous polyp
you don't know when it's coming but you
know it's coming it's a fact of life
every respiratory infection every
wheezing especially if you were smoker
its preparing for when the doctor has
you in the office they call you in that
little office he goes hey here are the
options what a sentence here are the
options you know it's coming uncle uncle
of mine just got diagnosed with throat
cancer you know great great dude didn't
really smoke you know how to but
occasionally you know and so every
sickness you get past a certain age it's
so funny it's one of the things in life
that completely goes 180 degrees the
other way being sick as a kids kind of
like fun I mean don't tweet at me and be
like it's not fun for Kayla who has
leukemia I'm not talking about that not
just I'm not saying that
please don't tweet at me it's not you
know whose own insured little magical I
get I write I'm not saying that I'm
saying when your [ __ ] sick as a kid
and you get out of school it's fun but
when you're an adult it is not fun
because you're just thinking about okay
dodged a bullet
every doctor visit over the age of 30
you're dodging a bullet that's all
because we all know the stories now we
all have enough stories now you collect
them as you go
through life and you're in your in your
teens you have very few yes people died
but it's vet the why is very apparent
they got in a car accident it was a DWI
it was an overdose somebody got shot
it's very cut and dry as to why this
happened and your 20s it might get a
little murkier like but you still kind
of know you know it's like five brain
can't it's a rare and your thirties
people died you just go haha oh that's
something something something not good
just these things start to happen as you
get older every decade it gets a little
bit less surprising you know forties is
a decade of look yeah the guy just had a
heart attack at Runyon hit his head his
head on a rock
heart attack didn't kill him but hitting
a head on a rock did my friend told me
that story the other day forty year old
the gay guy got a two year old daughter
just being I'm out done heart attack
head on a rock didn't die from the heart
attack died from me hitting the head on
the rock and running you know like two
people in Runyon Canyon died every week
yeah people don't talk about it
so I'm not trying to make you in a
hypochondriacs I'm just saying that life
is too short to not be hateful you know
what I mean people people don't
understand life is too short to hold it
in the bile the bile that courses
through your veins like that goo that
ran through the sewers Ghostbusters -
it's too short you gotta let it out you
gotta have a group of friends where you
can let it out you have to hate the
right people for the right reasons you
gotta hate the right things that's why I
hopefully you listen to the program
because I do a lot to help direct your
anger into the right places where it
should go where it's productive but life
is just too short you're gonna go it's
coming it's gonna happen sooner than you
think and you know spend your time on
this planet airing out your grievances
I'm telling you you're gonna regret it
spend time on the planet letting people
at the hotel front desk no the showers
not as warm as you would like in fact
you'd like it hot and it's not what you
consider hot have the engineer go in
there and check the room you only get so
long on this planet let the waiter or
waitress know exactly what you think of
the club sandwich if the bacon wasn't
crispy enough let them know don't hold
it in that when you hold it in that
becomes cancer let it out let it out I'm
telling you I went to the urgent care to
get diagnosed surge occurs quick you're
in and out boom boom boom
it's what I'm into I like the urgent
care because I feel like if I go to like
I still like a real doctor I'm gonna die
cuz they're gonna really look at me you
know they'll really figure out what's
going on it's the last thing I want so
urgent cares quick no I don't think any
of them are real doctors they're all
like UCB improv kids that are pretending
to be doctors the urgent in urgent care
is that they urgently want you out of
the office it's like a five-second
diagnosis in an urgent care they're like
hey what's up you like I'm bleeding
they're like a scream here's a script
and go and now that we're in LA you know
and the and the ticket ticket sells by
the way slow it down a little bit
because of the corona virus so I don't
want the half in half out and I talked
to Ben about this are we really gonna
sell these shows out we're gonna rock
out we're not gonna give a [ __ ] or we're
just gonna what we'll stay in the
[ __ ] you know in the bunker but I'm
not interested like half full theaters
of people coughing I want all in a roll
out like people are like oh that the
last episode you were saying you want a
pandemic I'm like here's what I want I
want it it we're in or out I don't want
anyone losing money but if we are me and
Ben have spoken about listen then we're
all just gonna stay in for a little
while
that's all that's what I was trying to
say I'd rather not I'd rather not people
lose money out there you know but I
don't want a halfway thing
where it's mostly hysteria and yet
everybody's losing money for no goddamn
reason
um but we're in the urgent care and now
the urgent cares job is to just tell
everyone going to the urgent care that
they can't test for coronavirus the
whole urgent care does listen if you're
concerned about coronavirus you have to
go to the ER we do not have the means to
test you here so literally people walk
in and they're like hey I want to be
tested for come on and by the way people
know symptoms no one cares these people
have no symptoms they just simply want
to get tested I just want to be sure I'm
like what what so you have those idiots
going so I go and I go in Monday morning
and Monday morning my throat I can
barely swallow pain I mean bad my
tonsils are huge feels like I have an
abscess in my throat and it's like
you're like [ __ ] so I walk in Monday and
I go hey they go okay
think of you traveled out of the country
recently I'm like I went to Vancouver a
few weeks ago doctor goes okay and then
I went like I wasn't even thinking I
went to the doctor thinking a lot of
Asians though and she liked pretended
not to hear it yeah she like ignored it
she was still looking at the chart like
I was trying to balance cuz I was a
Gavin Coover a few weeks ago she'd
probably yeah that wasn't okay I'm like
eh but I want to be honest a lot of
Asians over there again not being a
racist trying to get all the medical
information to be accurate I want you
know and she's like listen it looks like
your strep test is positive and I was
like [ __ ] yeah
thank God I was like that's good right
she goes yeah yeah I guess I go yeah it
is you know so then they give you a
steroid shot in your ass I don't even
know what that does it supposed to calm
your [ __ ]
you know I don't know what it's supposed
to do but it I guess the steroids you
know they're supposed to help I think it
boosts your immune system right whatever
you still feel like [ __ ] right maybe
they were the right steroids this was
one urgent care that could have
pretended to do it they could have just
pricked me with a pen and not done
anything what you know I they're
probably just kidding fake steroid shots
so I go to CVS and I my throat is like
just you know and I'm coughing a little
bit cuz you can't really swallow in the
water it's like what is almost
aspirating out of your mouth it's
horrible and then ever to CVS is looking
at yeah you know me and Ben just had
lunch at the Beverly Hills hotel that
was coughing at the table and
everybody's looking at you like [ __ ] is
this the guy is this patient zero is
this the guy who brings it to LA is this
the guy that brings it to the Beverly
Hills Hotel this [ __ ] right now
see the guy and I'm just there's a table
next to us talking about Elizabeth
Warren and I'm just sitting there going
and they're just these women are just
staring at me you know staring at me
their eyes judgmental behind their $400
sunglasses Warren I'm a fan of Liz and
another thing stop going on Twitter and
telling people where I supported Liz and
now I'm supporting Bernie yeah obviously
that's an op dies we get we get it you
self-important [ __ ] we get it you
self-indulgent pieces of [ __ ]
it absolutely logically follows that
you'd go from Liz to Bernie we get it
there's no [ __ ] explanation needed
keep you 280 followers mouths shut no
one needs you to your ten-point plan as
to why you're switching from Bernie to
[ __ ] Elizabeth Warren shut up it's if
you're going from Warren to Trump that's
fun that's fun and I want to hear it
and I want to see a Twitter thread I
would see a Twitter threat of a woman
who goes I supported Elizabeth Warren
I'm proud of the work she's done but now
that she's out of the race I'll be
switching my support 100% completely to
Donald Trump - Donald J Trump that's a
good thread that's worth our [ __ ]
time
tell us why you're going to drop now
that would be fun not Warren a Bernie we
get of course we get it I just think
that Liz did a great job but because of
sexism and because I just and I'm going
to support Bernie right now because I
feel like here's the candidate with the
but no I want to hear
I supported Liz but I'm now supporting
Donald Trump I'm supporting Donald J
Trump because I believe in our strong
economy strong borders that's a fun turn
to make I don't know his burning [ __ ]
here's what I would say people have
accused me they're like Oh Tim Dylan is
ironically trying to be a pretty pro and
now he's I'm there's nothing about I'm
not a Bernie bro at all I like Bernie I
probably vote for Bernie because he's
the anti-establishment candidate that
being said there's some things I don't
agree with them on um and I don't know
really what his platform will be in the
general election but a lot of it I would
agree with you know like people not
having to sell their blood plasma that
would be one that would be one that
would be a strong agreement I have with
Bernie Sanders that people shouldn't
have to sell their blood to live in this
country that's all I mean again I know
that makes me some type of Hollywood
sellout and chill that's my favorite
thing I like Tim Dylan's a shill for
Hollywood and I'm like yeah cuz but
Bernie Sanders is what Hollywood wants
there's not nobody wants that guy
I'm telling you right now nobody behind
the wheel of a Range Rover wants this
dude I'm telling you nobody in Hollywood
nobody on Wall Street nobody in Palo
Alto everybody wants somebody else he's
the only guy that really throws a scare
into people with money Trump doesn't
stop stop
I'm not saying Trump isn't at war with
other parts of the establishment he is
political establishment 100% but this
Trump does not bother rich people other
than aesthetically like they don't like
how vulgar he is and how crass he is but
he's not [ __ ] with them he said who's
gonna eliminate that carried interest
loophole he didn't do it he said he was
gonna reign Wall Street in I mean he's
done the opposite and listen the economy
is good it's good right now wages aren't
up you don't have insurance you're still
[ __ ] that's my thing I'm like listen
my friend's mother got diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer I mean this is a woman
that I considered defacing her grave
last week but I will now use her to make
a point
if I only considered it briefly and I
don't even know how much money that
would cost and I was just gonna write
Trump 20/20 on the grave so that other
people I just think it's funny to make a
grave a Trump supporter I think it's
hilarious to go to someone's grave and
put Trump 2020 all over their grave like
just put all kinds of I think that's
funny
this woman fought pancreatic cancer for
ten years and and lived and you know
inspired like walks and all this stuff
but like during that time went into deep
debt you know the you know mortgaging
the house over and over had to declare
bankruptcy you know eventually taking
the phone off the hook dodging creditors
and stuff and you're like she felt
guilty that she was still alive she was
like I feel guilty I'm saddling my
husband with this kind of dad I'm Ally
you know what kind of system is that you
know and the Republican answer to that
really is who cares I mean that's really
who cares that that's the Republican
answer to that is we we don't
that's truly what it is if there's a God
God's gonna figure it out we care about
we care about aborted fetuses we mention
them all the time we keep track of how
many they are you know how many aborted
fetus is and then the Republicans are
like you know how many aborted black
fetuses there are because Republicans
love black babies you didn't know that I
didn't know that either they adore black
children they love them especially when
they get to be teenagers so Republicans
want more black kids around I didn't
know but having gone on Twitter and read
about aborted fetuses and how many of
them were black and that Republicans
adore black people uh that's funny -
it's like you know during the whole
immigration argument they're like
immigrants come to this country they
take jobs from African Americans it's
like this is the angle now they're like
how are these African Americans gonna
make a living let's like remember when
you were flooding their communities with
cocaine so you could sell weapons to the
Contras remember that not too long ago
remember all that stuff um but you know
I just don't understand how you can I
understand being pro-life I'm with I hey
if that's your conviction good for you I
don't understand being really pro-life
and then hearing a story like the one
that I just told and going yeah you know
we'll let the market figure it out we'll
let the market figure out at what point
this woman should disconnect her phone
while she's fighting for her life trying
to be a mother and a wife fighting for
her life we'll just you know hey is that
even political anymore I mean honestly
is that even a political question like I
don't even understand if that's a
political question that that system is
[ __ ]
and the and the the answer to that on
the Republican side is Wow
yeah now and they'll go into this long
explanation about how why everything's
fine and you're like okay well what are
we gonna do now
you know but we need a trillion dollars
for the Pentagon
we need a trillion dollars for the
Pentagon need a trillion dollars to
non-stop build the future weapon systems
we need that we need to be in a forever
forever and ever and ever our
civilization should only dedicate its
resources to building ways to deliver
death to the poorest people in the world
that's what we should do every every
innovation we have should be about
trying to find another way to kill mass
amounts of people you know I mean we
need a trillion for that I don't know if
you can we can give any money to you you
and your pancreatic cancer you're a big
bummer big bummer but we like but I love
that the ideas like that somehow I've
gone Hollywood I hate the left i I don't
I'm not a Marxist I hate identity
politics I I think the corporate left is
particularly disgusting I think there's
some smart thinkers on the left there's
some smart thinkers on the right two
people who like one guy on the page gone
which I'm not even gonna read anymore
but one guy goes oh you can't do Bernie
Sanders is anything valuable to say and
quote Thomas solo it's like you can you
absolutely can absolutely kind Thomas
soul might hate everything Bernie
Sanders has to say that doesn't mean
that Bernie Sanders and Thomas soul
don't have some overlap there it
probably is the solutions are probably
different but again it's like the reason
that you don't have a podcast and that
no one listens to you and no one cares
about what you say is because you are a
person that can't fathom that you
haven't figured it all out that's really
what it comes down to out there wherever
you live and I'm sure it's great but
we're at wherever you happen to be you
don't like that there's somebody out
there that might add to the dialogue and
it might not line up with everything
that you figured out in your life in
your life of learning and acquiring all
the knowledge that you've acquired I
don't know how I imagine most of it
through podcasts and cable news because
you're smart guy and you know you know
that everybody that thinks to the left
of you is wrong about everything and
there's no way that any of them are
right thank you
I have such smart listeners I forget
sometimes how intelligent my listeners
are and how lucky I am to have them I'm
so lucky to have so many smart people
like when I have somebody on the patreon
they disagree with it then they go or
there's a lot of smart conservatives
though you should add a smarter
conservative on really so that's what
you wanted you wanted a smarter version
of the thing you hate it you wanted a
more effective version of what you hate
it okay won't find one you know we'll
find one for you that's my favorite
thing you're like turn this episode soft
tight alright hated this guy I can't
believe you had them on and next time
find a version of him that's smarter
what I want to be more enraged thank you
all you know the idea that you can't
hold different ideas in your head at
once like I think this woman should have
been given healthcare but I also
considered to fazing or grave these are
two ideas that were how
in my head simultaneously you know I
don't know the best way to do it I don't
know if getting rid of the private
health insurance is completely the way
that waited the way to do it I think
Medicare for all is probably the
direction we need to move in as a
country 100% um how you move in that
direction we'll see I don't know but
bernie is the only guy if you're if
you're a student of history and even not
history of [ __ ] the present which
takes a lot less just be a student of
the present understand what's happening
in front of you
Bernie's the only guy they're scared of
they're scared of him not even the
Republicans his own party the
Republicans are probably scared of him
too but his own party is frightened of
him you know Klobuchar Pete Buddha Jed
dropping out both endorsing Biden right
before the South Carolina primary is as
close as you get to a maneuver a
manufactured set of circumstances to
boost Biden Warren's staying in by the
way all of these things boost one
candidate yes Bernie didn't connect with
black people
you didn't connect with you know older
women older voters but that being said
one of the reasons that Biden got a
groundswell of support was because this
race had a lot of different people in it
up until the [ __ ] night before when
two of them said by the way vote binder
vote for Joe and that got him more
momentum now that doesn't mean that
Sandra's people don't have work to do
with young people a lot of young people
didn't show up he you know I think you
went a little too hard at Obama and I
think that's why a lot of the African
American you know Democrats that's a
sizable you know group there it's the
size but I forget the word but it's just
like a sizable part of their coalition
if the Democrats have always you know I
forget the I forget the word
I know everyone on Twitter I know word I
know word
what is it contingency what is like went
when you're it's an interest group
within the party I'm trying to think of
the word the word like they're a they
were important like women or an
important blank of the Democrats so
you're important and I don't know I
don't know I don't I know you're trying
to say if I can't ya ready there so you
know maybe Sanders is [ __ ] maybe you're
gonna have Joe Biden who is whose brain
is broken whose brain is melted who can
barely string words together who's very
creepy with women and children just a
creepy guy you're gonna run him you're
gonna run a guy who's the Washington
insider who's hopelessly corrupt whose
son is working everybody wanted his son
works for the same Ukrainian energy
company by the way isn't that fun you're
gonna run a corrupt guy with dementia so
if he does remember what he says it's
going to be a lie it'll be corrupt
because he's you know you're running
against Trump now Trump is another guy
who's a liar who I don't know people are
saying that he's in some stage of mental
decline he's doing a lot better than Joe
Biden maybe he is crushing adderall and
snorting I don't know but he's doing a
lot better than Joe but he's much better
than Joe Biden I don't know what to tell
you just old guy versus old guy you go
with Trump in terms of cognitive
abilities easily easily you go with
Trump you gotta [ __ ] yeah you know that
guy he's entertaining I mean Joe Biden
was not a vice president that anyone
truly gave a [ __ ] about he was just
there he was making gaffes in the
primary said Obama's the first nice
clean black guy that ran for president
like these are the things he was saying
in the primary I mean the Trump first
Biden debate will be the debate when we
go we don't need a country anymore it'll
be so embarrassing
we will call China
like a kid at a sleepover that's not
working out calls his parents will be
like come now don't wait get in the car
I'm ready now
we're ready let's go let's get out of
here we don't care how many bat flus you
got just come and run this thing please
one thing you guys know how to do is run
something efficiently you know sometimes
I'm somewhere and I don't have a wallet
that I want I just have a wallet that I
don't want and I'm so upset and I get
[ __ ] mad and I'm mad because to me a
wallet is something you should have as a
man as a big round you should have these
as a woman even as a woman you should
have a wallet as a wallet as a woman as
a woman a wallet a big wallet I'm doing
the Ridgid as Joe Biden here's some
language about Ridge inspire you
inspiring you Obama Biden Biden mama you
know we had no wallet when I grew up
there was a guy named kooky yeah this
old leather bastard wallet I used to put
it in the back of my pants but my ass
smell so I'd put it out on the table and
everybody say grandpa Joe that while it
smells like ass and I say yeah because
I've been working all day this country
was built by workers and built by smelly
asses like mine but leather wallets and
I put it on the table and then my my
wife would make stew and I would eat
that stew and I'd realize that things
were good you know baseball and so what
I decided to do is I decided to get a
Ridge wallet it's a minimal front pocket
smollett that's designed to streamline
what you carry every day every day you
carry things you have the things you
carry in you with you sort of with you
inside of you
and every day you work hard for this
country and you carry your babies and
your children you chopsticks in your in
your pouch and you need a bridge wallet
it's a minimal front pocket wallet it's
designed to streamline what you carry
there's thirty five star reviews what a
better way to carry your cash and cards
rubbish I'm kidding I'm doing that and
it's your button but I do love a rich
wallet
thank you for giving me rich wallet calm
/ someone L above above that that that
always just comes in the copy as an
example for me to put in the YouTube
video that's good
Ridge comm promo code Tim T I am if you
don't use a promo code [ __ ] off don't do
it Ridge comm / Tim Ridge well it's are
great we all use them you get a couple
of cards in there a little cash nothing
mod Chris 100 dollar bill your lawyers
phone number that's all you need to go
and [ __ ] tackle the world set it on
fire make something to yourself make
something of your family okay I love
about rich it's two metal plates bound
together by durable elastic band the
ridge looks nothing like a traditional
wallet you're it is give it to me
titanium carbon fiber and aluminum fiber
ensures it is an option for everyone
look at this [ __ ] thing this is hot
as [ __ ] okay you only need a few things
in there it's it's safe okay it's not
gonna fall apart okay [ __ ] look at
that little band it's nice
everybody wants and some come with a
clip it's up to you I'm telling you
right now folks ridge comm slash Tim you
got to do it you got to get the ridge
wallet I'm telling you if you don't
you'll regret it Joe Biden s several
Ridge wallets because you kept losing
his wallet kept losing his wallet and
shield Biden's like well you get a ridge
you damn fool you know there's something
likable about by because he's just just
so out of it yeah you know what I mean
what do you say last debate he's like
Tommy come lately no one knows
cuz everybody Jack and Chuck yeah he's
out of it you should hold man late
seventies you know yeah she'd be put out
to pasture he's about to be the
president she's running to be the
president of the United States the guys
should be walking around you know the
edge of his property
kind of muttering to himself yeah come
on in dad it's dinner time
that's what the stage your life you
should be at it's gonna be the president
whoa get a ridge wallet Ridge calm slash
Tim tea I am do you like that Ridge do
you like that Ridge I have a beet
prepared do you want to you really
oh yeah yeah here we go Wow old leather
wallet just stop it
Jesse smiling Baker liar get the new
Ridge that [ __ ] is fire stop talking
about white genocide in South Africa it
might be an issue but I don't know it
also might be hysteria Wu Han is it a
bioweapon maybe but stop your [ __ ]
slap in and get a rich wallet 911 didn't
happen the towers are still there
Thank You Ridge wallet comm / Tim what's
very funny it's very comedic what we do
here mm-hmm
many other podcasts are not funny and
they do better than us but they're not
funny
very interesting if you're a comic and
you're not funny you have a real chance
of making it like if your comedy is for
like I just it's amazing the main it
just if you don't have anything funny to
say this might be the job for you yeah
right truly like what somebody tells me
they're comic now I'm like Skye's not
funny I'm like you're gonna do well
you're gonna do very well gonna do very
well have nothing funny to say it's
gonna happen gonna happen for you Ridge
wallet comm slash Tim goodbye there's
nothing like you could I just I just I'm
having the the apartment I live in detox
from the strat terms and chemicals we're
having in a maids command and you know
having all the bedding taken out and and
sorry I'm in a hotel for a few days
there's nothing better than a nice hotel
there really isn't and I learned that
from my mother my mother loved hotels
people that really love hotels hate
their lives because that's what a hotel
is it's a break from your life it's like
let's get away from your father let's
just get out Oh another swim meet great
and we get to stay in a hotel it's just
far enough away where we can stay and I
marry it and have the breakfast buffet
and I don't have to look at this guy
that I'm married and I don't have to sit
in my house I don't have to sit in my
loveless home if you really love hotels
like you know you just you hate your
life you look around at the four walls
you live in there you go yeah but the
hotels nice it's a nice change of pace
it's a nice pretend and I remember that
my mother loved when we when I found out
that the swim meet was far enough away
we couldn't drive home the next day and
and my dad wasn't the dad from Forrest
Gump like he wasn't raping us and
drinking on the couch they just hated
each other they just didn't like each
other right they didn't like each other
after a while there was just nothing to
like after a while you hit a wall
you just hit a wall and you gotta find
then you gotta find a partnership it
makes sense and then most of it is like
raise the kids let's raise the kids some
of it's like let's make money you know
we've seen a husband-and-wife realtor
team in the suburbs they hate each other
they're just trying to do something so
that they don't have to hate each other
and and and God bless if it works maybe
I don't know my parents weren't [ __ ]
Realtors I'll tell you that much poor
Fox but every now and then we could get
away go to a hotel be away from our
lives from our home be away from all of
the things that make you cry that make
you sad you check into a hotel you're a
different person you're a guest you're
somebody's get I am a guest here this
situation is impermanent but it's
beautiful you clean up the room you
clean up after me you bring me food in
my bed I can eat my bed if I want cuz
I'm a guest things are special makes you
feel like when you were a kid and you
were sick in your left school and your
grandmother came and got you and said
what are you let's hit blockbuster on
the way home
let's get you what you want to eat
you're a guest this doesn't happen all
the time you're sick you've earned this
treat don't get a little [ __ ] okay
little Roy Rogers little Roy Rogers back
to the future
whatever you were watching at that time
in your life you know and it was
something nice and that's the way I feel
in a hotel I I check in and I want to
let them know I want to let soon as I
check into a hotel I want to let them
know I'm going to be a problem that's
the first the first thing I do when I
check into a hotel
is alert them to the fact that today
you're going to work today you're going
to go to work today I know that a lot of
you are young and hot and you think the
service industries for young hot people
and you see celebrities here and
occasionally you take a shot with them
and maybe they take in the room and [ __ ]
you or whatever what you think it's cool
it's cool
well let me tell you that all ends right
now because it's work it's work today
I've arrived first thing we do let's
talk about the room where am I going
yes I booked third party yes I booked
third party stop yelling that out like I
give a [ __ ] I'm a proud member of the
American people okay
I have privileges you don't even know
about I have pretend privileges that are
unearned that I will [ __ ] try it out
in front of you yes I booked your hotel
tonight yes it doesn't matter I'm still
gonna lie and I haven't assistant that
booked the room I said you booked third
fourth your hotel tonight and I go oh
did she oh did she
my assistant handles this I pick a nicer
hotel and then I usually say I go oh I'm
oh this isn't the Beverly Hills Hotel
where's this oh oh I guess this will be
okay I I walk into the hotel I look
around and I'm horrified no matter how
palatial and beautiful it is I'm kind of
off I'm like confused I'm confused I go
to check-in I go I don't know what
what's happening I try to get my
assistant on the phone which is very
tough because I do not have one
I try to get my assistant on the phone
there's a problem to reach the room not
a suite is the room now hold on hold on
that asian couple will be fine
you get to them in a minute they're
quiet people they will wait
they're quiet respectful people that's
why they're running the world they will
wait allow me this moment so explain to
me that the rooms not as sweet when the
room is too sweet ergo explain to me
what it is what is the room it's a bed
like a shelter is it quarantine is it
woollen quarantine yes gay guys thin gay
guy who thinks he's the shape you're at
work today
you're at work today I'm so I apologize
okay I'd like to be on cocaine sucking
everyone's [ __ ] too but guess what we
got to work so the first thing I do is
we let them know room services what 24
hours in a full menu can I get the
restaurant food delivered to my room or
am I gonna have to go that in-house
dining menu that in-house dining menu or
will you bring me up your restaurant
food to my room
already they start to kind of like you
like I like yeah well should be able to
work something out okay what floor am I
on - I'm on floor two right now but I
got a better at a better room that's why
I took floor two but usually if they
give me a low floor I go I'm sorry do
you even you have rooms on those floors
you have guest rooms that's not some
type of is that not like an underground
garbage facility that the hotel uses do
you actually have a room and press them
I like to call I like to call up as soon
as I get in a room I like to call the
front desk ago hi am I in the wrong room
oh no they oh this is it I go this is it
I think like this you go then that's
fine okay yes Hey
Hey
it's fine I'll make two that's a great
one I go I'll make you I'll make do and
I call I call about five minutes later I
go you know water in the shower
is it hot I like to steam in the shower
a little bit I also would like a seat in
the shower like a marble ledge I can sit
on and steam I like to after the shower
I like to spend 20 minutes just with the
water running really hot because of
climate change and then breathe in the
vapor of the shower it opens me up
because I speak for a living is that any
way we can do that any way we could find
a seat for me in the shower I don't love
the water I I noticed a little orange
under one of the seats at my rooms I
called up I said now there's a there's
an errant piece of fruit in the room was
that in someone else's mouth and had
coronavirus that's the first thing I
said I go with someone coughing on that
that had coronavirus is that is that
part of the Welcome package haze the
orange under the under the seat part of
the Welcome Packet because what I'm
about to do is come down to the lobby
and start coughing so is that what you'd
like cuz I could come down to the lobby
start coughing yelling woo Han right now
because cuz I'm a wild [ __ ] so
what I can do is I could come down to
the lobby
literally bare ass start coughing
yelling woo hell is that what we want
yes or no let me know I'm here to help
you I'm here to help you okay that's all
I want it to be nice I want it to be
nice like at the Carlyle Hotel they knew
what we're about we checked in put us in
room 911 immediately I go they get it
they got it
room 911 didn't even ask if it was an
issue just put us right in room 911 in
New York City a beaut that's a beaut
that's a hotel that gets you that sees
you and goes [ __ ] yeah understands what
was the what what you know when you were
a kid did you go on vacations ever once
we went to Disneyland everyone fought
and then we never went on vacation again
we just gave up on it Disneyland in
California or a Disney World in Florida
how old were you 12 we drove all the way
across like in a
we rented and someone had smoked a bunch
of cigarettes in it everyone fought and
everyone hated each other the air
conditioning didn't work and then we
just we literally never went on vacation
ever again my mom would be like anyone
want to go on vacation this summer and
everyone would go nope we're good and
then we would just she would cry and
then I went on I went on I went on see
he talks I went on I went on very good
we'll do it again next week I stopped
harassing van out there by the way yes
oh and also hotel hotel tonight please
sponsor the podcast thank you
yeah good idea I will listen I gotta be
honest with you no tell tonight because
we sail all wild [ __ ] on here but let's
get [ __ ] real nobody knows luxury
like [ __ ] much nobody knows luxury
like I do you listening to me okay
nobody understands luxury okay like I do
you might not like that that might not
be nice for you cuz I'm not some young
you know half black half asian you know
hot you know whatever
pansexual wet-nurse I don't know what
you want but I'll tell you right now
nobody knows luxury like just that Irish
man from Long Island I know it all I've
got class for years the Irish have been
[ __ ] on and called animals for good
reason and I've worked hard to fight
that stereotype by going to restaurants
in hotels at five no money in the bank
I'll die I don't care I spend my money
on niceties luxuries little macaroons
they they brought the room-service
little macaroons eat them you know
that's why I know this [ __ ] hotel
tonight
now hotel tonight is for people that are
a lot it's your marketing right now it's
people that have [ __ ] last minute
people that you know they come into a
city or whatever and they're there like
and it's a great app and whatever and I
understand that but I'm telling you
right now you got some nice hotels on
there you need you need daddy to open
the luxury division of hotel tonight
that's what you need
luxury hotel tonight luxury I like
hotels and this is the slogan are you
ready
hotel tonight I like hotels because I
hate my life
[Laughter]
Hotel tonight be a person for 24 hours
be a person till 12:00 p.m. maybe one if
you get a late check-out that's what you
need to start marketing ass
are you disgusted with your
circumstances your decisions your
friends your family how about a little
trip for 24 hours you can exist in a
completely different environment where
no one can legally tell you to leave
hotel tonight do you hate your life
perfect hotel tonight I love hotels
because I hate my life
that's that's direction need that him I
went when I was a kid to Disney World
I've talked about this ad nauseam I've
bits about it on stage I'm not gonna go
into it my parents went to kind of like
save their marriage it was a [ __ ]
disaster I went back when I was in the I
was obtained sir in a dance troupe I did
the boogie Woogie Bugle Boy this is when
I was an actor from six to twelve I was
a [ __ ] actor you nobody's done
anything in this audience six to 12
hours an actor I was in nothing really
not a lot I was in the community theater
I was in some [ __ ] uh and y-you like
student felt like listen you know I
tried I got to like second callback
third callback for grace under fire and
then Brett Butler that drunk didn't
choose me she chose to sweet life Cody
one of them villain heard Cody yeah well
whatever that was probably a better
investment long-term Oh Sprouse Cole
Cole Sprouse yeah isn't that isn't that
yeah aren't they that isn't that the Zac
and that two [ __ ] twinks on a boat or
something yeah The Suite Life of Zack
and Cody
yeah what's yeah The Suite Life of Zack
yeah Cole Sprouse and dylan sprouse is
browses they were on the dance tonight
accrues and
it shows those [ __ ] whatever no bygones
and I was a tap dancer before cool black
guys took it over like Savion Glover
who's a genius and then everybody wanted
to go see stop but before that fat white
man used to dance in this country like
Jackie Gleason this is what Trump got
elected fat white man who were light on
their feet used to dance and people
loved it and the cool black I started
dancing and then one of the white people
gonna do they vote for Donald J Trump
what happened was when I went to the
Disney World
I thought we'd be in like a theater or
something you know and in the dance in
the dance classes there was me and it
was one other if the fat kid there was
another guy and here's the fat guy I
don't even know if he was gay or not I
think it was sad or if he wasn't gay his
name was George and my dad had nothing
to be compared like masculine or
competitive about with me he was never
like oh we weren't in sports so he
couldn't be like we're gonna kill the
Tigers today or whatever and [ __ ]
little Lincoln so he's like you're
better than that fat George dies it's
like you're a better dancer than Jordan
like I know I am he's like you're gonna
[ __ ] I'm sure they'll give you the
Bugle Boy you know that's all he could
be competitive about with me you know
poor guy but you know have more kids
you selfish boomer I'm sure there's
someone else when it came out that would
have been better point is fat George
didn't get it I got it I was a bugle boy
so I get to go down to Florida you know
with all these you know like truly
talentless predominantly Jewish women a
lot of Dana's a lot of Rebekah's and
just you know like not that good so we
go down to Florida you have go play that
play the song for boogie Woogie Bugle
Boy I want people to hear what it sounds
like it's an annoying night
twenties like [ __ ] like let me make
sure it's not copyrighted yeah right
okay yeah I'm sure it is
yeah it's copier all right but it's like
the bugs gonna be yeah
the Tuskegee Airmen are fine or whatever
I don't know but what it was [ __ ] and
they [ __ ] we perform on this stage
outside in Disneyworld that's by the
bathrooms so all these fat tourists are
trying to go there on a bathroom or
performing for the bathroom line
literally and it smells like [ __ ]
because the [ __ ] is wafting out from the
bathroom 120 degrees and we're just
flailing around on this stage and the
heat this is what show business really
is
that's what other people get into comedy
like it's not fear or it's like a it's
not supposed to be it's watching your
life get ground up like meat you idiot
so I came from this [ __ ] so I knew how
[ __ ] so we're like flailing our arms
around and dancing and it's the number
plays over and over again right so
there's no new number there's no new
dent like it's just you saw the one
dance and and that's like boom and then
it goes it starts again it goes the
boogie-woogie boom show these fat
tourists on the line I like she then
they start to turn their back to us
because they've had an I mean they've
seen enough so literally I'm watching
fat tourists on a bathroom line just
turn their back to you in the middle of
like that to me is his Disney World like
that that was you and then at the end of
the trip we went on Splash Mountain
right and that was fun
so that's Disney World and that's life
for most people he'll heat the smell of
[ __ ] and then one moment of
weightlessness and then they here's a
picture that they'll sell you that's
what it is you walk through the smell of
other people's [ __ ] you're just sweating
you don't know where you're going you
don't know why you're there you're
embarrassed you're afraid and then at
the end you get to go down the log flume
you have one moment of weightlessness
that's all life if you get a photo you
know
well never did it for me but then my dad
my dad actually to his credit took me to
a [ __ ] cool place called the Blantyre
which was a [ __ ] castle in
Massachusetts I talked about this on the
show before that I was in too because we
saw people that were work in class get
abused and that made me and my dad happy
because we poor people love seeing other
poor people get abused and when the
woman the old woman was out she's like
last Maurice I've done everything all my
planning has been with Maurice I don't
know who you are go and find him go in
but when you see an old woman with a
chunky jewel necklace throw her hand and
someone face go-go-go for me now be calm
it's great okay see I haven't gone full
Bernie bro and and the Blantyre was cool
when a few other places went this place
to Chatham she parted company doesn't
exist anymore
that was cool you know everybody goes on
these all-inclusive and I get it cuz
they're regular people and there's
nothing wrong with being a regular
person it's never really interested me
but many of you seem to be having a fine
time doing it but the all-inclusive
thing or the cruise thing or the I just
I it's kind of gross to me I think going
out nature is cool going to a different
city is cool learning things on your own
letting things happen organically but
the idea that like when you're treated
like cattle which is how a lot of people
go on vacations they're treated like
cattle and they're basically there they
go these people can't make any decisions
for themselves and they're right they're
right they can they're right yeah here's
how much these people can make this year
endorsements still mat that shocked me
in the presidential race like
endorsements matter like Jim Clyburn of
South Carolina endorsing Biden matters
it's like guys you know these people are
they've been on your TV you've seen them
you know what they're about and you
still need somebody to go
no you click that lever you vote for
this person these are grown adults these
are grown adults who need another person
to go I think you should vote for this
person oku I mean so that's my problem
with a lot of these vacations you just
don't
you're not allowed you know it's it's
all you're corralled into a group and
you're like here's what we're gonna do
here's what we're gonna do and I'm sure
a lot of them are fun listen I work a
lot I don't wanna thought I travel a lot
for work um I understand that there's uh
but to me it's like it's more fun I
think it's a much better story to go to
a place with your fiancee and you go on
a vacation and that and then she gets
kidnapped and you have to save her and
of course you don't save her that's
Hollywood [ __ ] she's gets killed but
then you come back from that trip and
you're a different person you understand
things that you didn't understand
previously you know we were able to kind
of process the world in a different way
to me I think that's better I don't know
I could be wrong maybe I am but you know
but that's my whole thing with uh was we
were uh where we're headed
I don't think Bernie's gonna win which
is a bummer but he really could he could
um his fans that are kind of throwing
their hands up break up at a great tweet
he's like you [ __ ] graphic designers
you can it is still viable you're
sitting in a coffee shop you know how
are you less tough than an 80 year old
guy who had a heart attack true you know
it's true he's still out there I hope
that he wins
I really hope and it would be
interesting general election campaign to
see those two guys go at it you know out
as long as Bernie doesn't do something
stupid and crazy with the open borders
or whatever I think he's got a really
good argument against Trump
you know you know that being said
what do I know you know I mean I think a
lot of it is gonna come down to like
what the [ __ ] is this virus gonna do
what's the economy gonna do is this a
blip is this a [ __ ] real-deal thing
you know two months from now are we
gonna be broadcasting literally from
like a safe house somewhere
I mean banner just spraying each other
with things we're broadcasting in dude
we should have done full hazmat suits we
should have done full hazmat suits for
the show full hazmat suits have fun when
you can't call it'll bit when you're out
[Laughter]
and then and then turn around the
waitress go slice slice tomato to bring
us life you know is there anything
better than a there anything better than
except Amade Oh focus very you know good
deep red slice of tomato care that
Monsanto dyed it who gives a [ __ ] a
slice a [ __ ] tomato will change your
life just make you a better person you
know make you a better person the other
things I wanted to talk about I think
it'd be great if hotels tonight did the
sponsors I just don't know if that's
gonna happen reach out to them yeah to
tweet at them they'd sponsor the show
suite hotel tonight guys and check your
avatar before you tweeted them okay if
it's an end white genocide avatar
let's not tweet it them okay that might
not be the you know
you know like let's just check our
avatar and make make sure that our
avatar might be appropriate for the
corporate sponsorship we're trying to
get from hotel tonight it's a great
[ __ ] app and I got a lot of status on
I should be giving so much more free
[ __ ] I plug people for free all the time
I get a lot from the steak houses in New
York City I talk about quality
Restaurant Group quality meets quality
Italian all that stuff except I ate a
quality Bistro and I was not happy
really not happy I hope they get it
together but I hate to very early on and
I think they'll get it together I hope
they get it together because it was
really I mean it was a problem yeah it
was a problem and and this is my family
that's involved in some of that and I
love them but I I it was it was an
affront to human decency that restaurant
at that particular moment they brought
over a hunk of butter and they said we
have butter service that we're doing a
parody on like bottle service ago we
have butter service and I went wow wow
what's going on why are you bringing a
hunk of butter its stomach churning to
see a hunk of butter and today guys you
don't understand what I mean hunk I mean
a hunk like it was like a foot of butter
different flavors of butter it's now
just a foot of butter and then they put
it on the thing with different spices
and herbs and then it's still not good
it's like doesn't taste good bad bad
figure it out quality meats one of my
favorites quality Italian love it
Smitham olinsky's classic pound Angie
great figure it out quality Bistro
figure it out a lot of people listening
to this could be a great pre theatre
restaurant figure it out that French
onion soup was [ __ ] bad it's not good
watery not good I pulled the manager
aside it's lovely Asian woman I went
right up thrown away I didn't but I went
up to her and I said this is one of the
worst meals I've ever had in my life
I looked right at her and I said hi how
are you good I said this is unacceptable
it's one of the worst meals I've ever
had in my life and I don't know what
you're gonna do
I said I don't know what you're gonna do
here because I can barely even come up
with suggestions to make this better
because it was such an affront to human
decency that the meal the chocolate
mousse was served on a slate like it
looked like human [ __ ] mousse looks like
human [ __ ] so what you got to do with
chocolate mousse is like make it pretty
make it pretty you can't put it on a
slate like it's [ __ ] I was I was aghast
I'm gonna give it another shot we might
pop in there when were in the city for
Caroline's
I might give it another shot I wasn't
happy and I was vocally unhappy my
mother I grew up with a woman who would
put the service industry through all
types of hell it's one of things I
respected about her okay okay
and she would demand things demand and
stop with all your [ __ ] liberal
socialist like [ __ ] I feel bad for
working-class no you don't you're just
mad that you suck you don't care about
the working class the working class many
number Trump rallies and many of them
are monster card shows you don't care
talk about all these people now that I
talk with a working class and they start
quoting Proust stop you in the working
class never met each other okay somebody
who's broke because they're trying to be
a slam poet he's not the working class
it's actually the opposite someone was
the luxury of pursuing comedy and not
working is by definition not the working
class my mother used to say to like
waiters and waitresses should go should
be like I want the French fries lightly
cooked and then the fries would come out
and they wouldn't be and she would look
at the waitress and she'd go listen I
gotta I gotta be honest with you she
goes if the chef's can't make french
fries I don't know that he's in the
right business she because I just wonder
what I wonder
what's going on back there I'm confused
you know she was sure just torture
people
my father watched her once get up in a
diner and walk walk into the kitchen and
my dad just saw a bunch of like Greek
guys like staring at my mother she just
yelled at a guy cuz the fish wasn't done
the right way
you know she wanted what she wanted when
she wanted it brown the cheese on the
pizza if the pizza box got lifted up in
the restaurant and it was not brown
cheese she's got a heads got to go back
in got to go back in but you'd call over
this little [ __ ] and she'd be like come
here and he'd be like a fat [ __ ] and
he'd walk over and she'd go hey Giuseppe
can you put this back in the can you put
this back in the oven
your little garlic monkey Thanks so let
let him out let him know if you're
spending money it's okay to hit people
it's okay to hurt them it's okay to just
smash them take the phone right out of
their hand I'm talking to you my child
no you're not grab that phone your
mother's at work it we've been - we've
been too nice to people this is why I
think you I I am for giving people
health care so I can treat them like
[ __ ] do you understand that I care about
people if you don't complain you don't
care I want you to be the best I've done
this a million times but I want you to
be the best so if I see you not being
the best I have to tell you you're not
being the best or if your institution
does not being the best gotta let them
know I don't I don't rat I'm gonna rat
so I won't tell on you but I will just
make your life miserable by being myself
a lot that's all but that's what I want
you to have hell the church I don't
think you should get cancer I think you
should be able to go to the doctor and
then you should be able to go to work
and and [ __ ] deal with me cuz it's
work time okay I'm sorry
okay guy who's not as good-looking as he
thinks he is otherwise he wouldn't be
working
Hotel I'm sorry it's not time to just
take Molly and zone the [ __ ] out wake up
wake up I got a lot of issues is my room
a corner room or not oh it's not oh we
got a lot of work to do open up the
ledger what do we got
what kind of rooms we got left that's
the reality you know that's why and this
this is the working class argument
provide the people with health insurance
provide them with health insurance so
you can spit on them
I mean um is that wrong I think it's
pretty good provide them with a living
wage and make a work for it climb over
the counter in the Wendy's you can't you
cannot yell at a [ __ ] kiosk you can't
threaten a kiosk a touchscreen thing
that's why I need real people you can't
get real people out of the workforce
can't get real people out of work for us
that's why I support giving people
health care giving them child care so
that their children can be looked after
while they are brutalized that's what
I'm gonna mark sit I don't believe in
this horseshit were leaked we're not all
equal you dumb [ __ ] we're not equal at
all you're gonna get the boot in the
[ __ ] face but fine Suga health care
you should get health care but you
should also be beaten beaten a lot of
that is some of that is kidding but a
lot of that is not I rely truly I was
beaten I'm beaten now listen all of you
giving me your opinions and your [ __ ]
tweets that's that's you spitting in my
face because I have to listen to that
and some of it I have to take into
account now none of it I do but I've had
so
shitty jobs the idea that you don't
learn anything from a shitty job this is
where those [ __ ] Bernie stands and
all you [ __ ] this is where you don't
look you don't know anything about life
truly truly don't know anything about
life you're all from Vermont you're all
white you're disgusting the point is
this I oscillate every week from what
left all right all the ante four people
are mad now but the other people have
their torches up next week they are
extinguishing their torches angrily and
that and the ante for people with the
black things like this imagine people
voting for Bloomberg imagine believing
in less than nothing this guy's
obviously buying your vote buying the
race he's made no qualms about it
it's his strategy buying the elections
is strategy people that believe in you
know mayor Pete or Amy people that voted
for them they don't believe in anything
either but they they just believe in
nothing right they believe in tomato
soup civility snow like they like the
holidays they're just those people
Bloomberg's people believe in less than
nothing it's a nihilism that I could
never even get near on my darkest
blackest day I mean they believe in less
and nothing they're their pawns in an
operation there's they can't they're not
getting anything out of it woo him
unless you are will unless you are woo
him it's not I went to the thing it's
not it's trap it's post-nasal but I know
rich people from New York City they
voted for him sure I know that yeah sure
but I mean if you're a [ __ ] Tennessee
and you vote for a guy like Mike
Bloomberg and you think he gives a [ __ ]
about you just disease and you're what
is your criteria for who you elect how
many commercials you see then vote for
Hardee's yeah I mean that's it
vote for Chili's if your only criteria
is how many commercials are on the air
in a span of time but that's the country
you're living in
that's the country you're living it
you're living in the country where
millions of people around the country
cast their votes from Mike Bloomberg
because he bought up all the air tent or
the air time on their television he
bought up all the air time on their TV
so in between a practical jokers reruns
there was lizard Bluebird going hi Mary
man abandoned and then these people
while they were eating you know a bowl
of Velveeta cheese salsa that they had
bounced on this stomach they think they
swallow Bloomberg's ad and they said oh
I guess I'll vote for him because I
believe in less than nothing I don't
even know there's an election happening
I barely know what these what what these
what's even happening but I'll just do
what the the billionaire on TV tells me
to do I tip very well I will say this I
tip really well I think you should
always tip well this will be the closing
thing of the show because everyone's
gonna be like all you talk [ __ ] about
service people I only talk [ __ ] about
the bad ones the good ones I don't talk
[ __ ] with and I'm not addicted but I was
a bad service industry person so I
understand what it is and you do have to
just get better at what you do in it you
know but I kept really wide so you
should always tip really really well
even if you have a disagreement with
somebody like there was a person it was
a woman who used to work at his diner
and she was very rude to me and I said I
was kind of a dick back to her but I
still tipped her really well and
afterwards as it was walking out of the
diner I spit in the face and and then
she ran out after me and I and me and my
friends hit her with our car and but I
tip 20% always always always 20%
tim miller comedy con for all the dates
for all the tickets for all the tickets
in the dates and the tickets and the
dates and the tickets
at records all of the shows are coming
up we're Caroline's in New York City or
Philly ah Des Moines March 20 March 19th
to the 21st with helium comedy club in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania come on out to
that where are we Ben tell them we're
Des Moines at the funny bone March 26th
through the 28th des Moines Iowa come on
out that's Johnny Gosch territory yeah
are you gonna talk to anybody out there
when you're I don't think so I might I
don't know Omaha's really where it
happened
I mean Omaha's the hole Franklin's
killed but I was where I mean I might
take a photo in front of his house
everyone be like that's the guy who
kidnapped Johnny I somehow got arrested
I wasn't even alive I blame it on me
they blame it on red cop you're free
nice kravitz LEM buddy oh you didn't
promote caroline's by the way well when
does this come out just yet yes listen
tonight
Caroline it's March 12th through the
14th yeah Caroline's a lot of tickets
have sold there's some laughs get him
yeah there's a sold-out there's some
left Friday Saturday then we got
Bloomington House of comedy April 9th
through the 11th listen guys this is my
nightmare this is the Mall of America
April 9th to the 11th and Bloomington
Minnesota this is my literal nightmare
we're gonna film a lot of content it's
gonna be fun
please get tickets for that show
Bloomington Minnesota Mall of America
April 9th through the 11th I mean this
is like everything I talk about it's the
physical manifestation and
representation of everything I've ever
spoken about on the show it's like an
indoor roller coaster that like drops
you into a vat of blue cheese it's an
absolute nightmare we were a disgusting
country but please come and enjoy it
with me after there where are we Albany
that's a funny bone funny motor normally
Albany is a nothing place
it's just opioid addiction and nothing
yeah April 17th through the 18th there
yeah and then back to Texas Dallas
taxes at hyena's April 23rd through the
25th yeah April 23rd through the 25th
Dallas I love Dallas it's one of my
favorite cities I adore Dallas if you
don't know why I like Dallas go to
corporate Steakhouse and listen to that
episode I describe what I love about
Dallas and then it's that everywhere you
look is all protect us then the live
podcast in LA Wow I think it's almost
sold out live podcast Roosevelt Hotel
Los Angeles wild we should add a second
shot gonna talk about it and see if you
can add a second show I don't know if we
can maybe we add a second show that that
night well that night we have the Late
Show ready maybe we had a Sunday show I
don't know
we'll see what we can do then you're
going to Columbus every funny bone yeah
we're not we can't do it we're not gonna
do the whole tour but go on the [ __ ]
website get Columbus funny bond Fox
Tamila comedy calm you know if we do 40
dates here we're gonna say I'm done
you're going to or buy Michigan oh I'm
showing that tickets are sold out for
the Netflix thing a lot of people are
saying tickets are sold out for the
Netflix thing let's find that let's see
if we can add a show let's hear we can
do I don't know if we can do that um I
mean we've done a lot of great things
here today I've made the case for
national health insurance better than
anyone running ass why do poor people in
health insurance you can demean them you
can you can really you know hit them
with a fire poker you got you know
that's why they deserve it that's why
they deserve it like if you're a lord in
England they're going you know you're in
a horse and carriage and there's like a
little street urchin and then look up at
you and that's it on their face from the
mills you know get out of here running
around that little bastard should be
cared for but they don't that to get in
the [ __ ] carriage and go to the nice
house earn it next week I'll just be
like Stalin I just had a nice lunch
folks and I become a monster
after I have a nice lunch well you're
like Oscar you switch every week Oscar
does switch every week
Oscar is the cat who's not my cat but
he's a friend of ours and we a friend of
ours owns him and we do a lot of content
with Oscar he's a big fat grey cat that
everyone says always wouldn't be fat so
shut the [ __ ] up that the term is fat
cat also he's not as fat I mean I know
people say but he is just a lot of it's
fur but Oscars been a member of most of
the terrorist groups like he's an aunt
of um he went to Charlottesville he went
in the alt-right he's he's been in a
glacier to Crystal which is the Filipino
thing he's been in Golden Dawn which is
some right-wing thing in Greece he's
been a violent communist he's been in
and Ansar al-islam he's been in Isis
he's been in al-qaeda
right now he's currently working for dry
air Boston ro in Brazil as a culture
minister you know Jules my podcaster Tim
Dylan coming soon we will let you know
when we are setting up a and bonfire
comm slash store slash to attend Dylan
show those links are in Tim's box that's
some merch [ __ ] get some shirts get
some ads get some mugs